the michael knowles public health
protection pledge just got a major boost
on capitol hill yesterday you may recall
a month or so ago i mentioned on this
show that i would not vote for any
candidate for federal office in november
that did not vote to subpoena dr fauci
and to take away his salary a
congressional candidate in north
carolina beau hines took my off-the-cuff
remark and wrote it up as a formal
pledge at which point dozens of
congressional candidates and sitting
members signed it
then a couple weeks ago arizona
congressman paul gosar entered my pledge
almost verbatim as a formal house
resolution meaning that sitting members
of congress could now sign on
to co-sponsor the bill
at this point
dr fauci basically evaporated into thin
air
that once ubiquitous face
that folksy little voice
that pompous scientific smirk that had
dominated every media platform for two
years
just gone
overnight
the political winds had clearly shifted
against fouchy and he went into hiding
the only thing that was lacking was
support in the senate
which we now have thanks to senator rand
paul
senator paul has actually gone even
further than my pledge called for he has
proposed an amendment that would not
only investigate fauci and stop paying
his salary but would abolish his
position
altogether
the paul amendment would reorganize
fauci's national institute of allergy
and infectious diseases into three
separate research institutes each with
its own director removing entirely the
ability of one power-hungry bureaucrat
to amass the kind of unprecedented power
that fauci took for himself during the
covid lockdowns
this is excellent news
we need to push this over the finish
line do not let the liberals fool you
into thinking that they are done
exercising the unprecedented power that
they took during covid
do not let them fool you into thinking
that they are done with kovid period
they have calmed down now because it's
an election year and the covid policies
are destroying them at the polls but
they've kept the tsa mask mandate
they've kept biden's national emergency
declaration
they've kept the same infrastructure in
place to whip it all back up again the
minute the midterms are behind them do
not let them do it
as we reach the official two-year mark
of 15 days to slow the spread that's
happening tomorrow
call your congressman
call your senator and have them do
everything they can to restore our way
of life and make sure that that little
power mad twerp and his technocrat
buddies never get the chance to shut
your country down again
i'm glad you like that clip now i need
you to ring the bell please
you'll get the notifications you'll
subscribe and then also head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe to the michael knowles show
m-i-c-h-a-e-l space canon w l e s space
s h o w subscribe right now you will get
all of our latest episodes we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you